[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hot shot
racing
i really respect the energies he said
that with
you know that guy had one job
and that that job was to scream
hot shot racing and he delivered i think
i feel like i'd hire him you know
what i'm saying because that is what i'm
saying
oh hi everyone i didn't see that let me
turn the game sound down that's probably
too loud and then myself up a little bit
yup
yup hello friends
how are you guys doing uh did i set this
up incorrectly i think it's right
i maybe did not
my internet is being so weird today i
feel like i'm capped
uh yeah hi everyone this stream is
sponsored um
by curve digital the publisher of
hotshot racing
but one of you probably know
i do really love racing games and this
is um
an arcade eraser as you can tell by the
way that it looks
which is just a wonderful nostalgic
experience
if we're being honest i'm trying to load
youtube
and have been for five minutes-ish and i
just can't
i don't know what's wrong with my pc
okay everything seems to be fine
there's a game mode where it gets
gradually quicker
that's wild
what are you complaining about courtney
are you complaining about me playing
among us
that's what that sounds like i can't
tell though
uh if i play among us too much it's just
because um people ask me to
and as a person who is socially
isolating alone in my own apartment
a great social outlet remember that
i'm alone in my own apartment
i did just take the thumbnail picture
yeah i was laughing
i made sure i was laughing to be fair
but i was laughing
um because i tested the capture first it
is unfortunate that we have this little
black bar at the bottom i couldn't get
rid of that
during my test
um i'm unsure why that's happened
okay buddy uh but everything seems to be
working
i think this slaps uh what was i saying
oh yeah just remember you know that
some of us are isolating alone and it's
an experience and and playing social
video games is a really cool outlet
for uh literally never looking a human
in the eyes
because i haven't done that in the last
time i saw anyone was a demon soul
stream i think
so you know do with that what you will
um okay
so yeah for anyone who's unfamiliar with
hotshot racing
there is a new dlc available right now
it's free
uh you get barrel barrage mode
which takes hot shot racing's trademark
breakneck speed and adds explosive
barrels to the mix wow that sounds
sick launch from the rear of each
vehicle barrels explode on contact with
competitors cars inflicting damage and
making each dash for the checkered flag
more perilous
that rules i love arcade racing games
they're so fun
um at a boss level grand prix which
expands the roster of championships and
hot shot racing with the boss level
grand
prix including four new circuits
and all game modes are available across
all tracks included or introduced sorry
in the boss level grand prix
um let me pull that over there
i think everything's all good i think so
oh let me just see if my tea is
drinkable yet how's everybody
doing hmm
this is quite warm i love it
i agree mick social interaction is going
to be very strange
when slash if they ever come back to
normal that's what i'm saying
so let's start with a single race shall
we
i think i might do the barrel barrage
one
because it sounds ridiculous the marina
is that gonna be like a san francisco
type
yeah sounds good let's do it
she does look very cool
i think i'm gonna go she believes
driving is an art form when you come and
she strives for the perfect racing line
and she's not about to let the opinions
of others distract it from my vision
right i just like the glasses
okay
why don't we just start with your little
balanced car to be
first joshua how dare you ask me that
question you know the answer to that
question joshua
it was made with a kettle not a
microwave the tea
also but it is in my um my cool
thermos huh yeah yeah
i never use thermoses and i'm kind of
amazed by how uh
like hot this is on the inside while
being very cool on the outside i know
that's the whole thing like that's the
entire point
but i'm still like wow it really works
because i don't really use them very
often
um my mighty bush said i'm surprised how
much is still streaming even after
getting a new job it will stop i will
cut back um this is all stuff that i
kind of had
planned or scheduled already so
yes the uploads will you will see a
change there i'm not going to tell you
you want
because i didn't do that i am already
exhausted
[Applause]
how do you get like a bugatti veyron
looking thing
what
i love it okay maybe not san francisco i
mean it could be i'm not drifting
correctly i should figure out how to do
that there's gotta be there it is oh
that's more than i hoped for okay
daytoda
okay okay we'll get it we'll get it oh
that's right i picked some barrel mode i
completely forgot that i have done that
okay that is totally a bugatti veyron
that's cool as hell dude
okay no it is it i take it back it is
san francisco
it totally is i lived there uh for
three years i was technically in the bay
area for four years
oh not my fault not my fault not my
fault
i also love the tasteful amount of
polygon shapes i am strongly in
agreement
um no i i spent
a lot of time at arcades as a kid
um because of my dad actually um
my dad i feel like i've spoken about
more and more on this channel um
recently
is an absolute champion oh gosh oh gosh
oh gosh oh gosh
and it's also just a child at heart so
he loves theme parks he loves thrill
rides and he loves arcades so we spent a
lot of time in arcades
um just like as i like sunday outing
you know playing arcade games which i
love
but i also do love a racing game and
this is the combination of the two
things
my car's on fire oh oh it's just
progressively getting more on fire
mike's in trouble there too hey bud do
you want to hang out at least we look
cool
am i going to get second i haven't used
my barrels
hmm there we go
i just pooped a barrel out let's do more
of that
i may have missed that one there did
anyone play blur
because that is a uh
another sort of arcade racer that i
really like
[Applause]
i if any of you would like to we'd have
to like get enough people that it would
even be possible
um to fill the lobby up but if anyone
would like to i'd be down to do a
multiplayer game with with uh
viewers right now if we can figure out
how to do it um
oh that was unfair
a bad turn of events there i was going
pretty well
it's going pretty well i agree blair was
underrated
carlos what's the first thing i'll do
when life is hopefully back to normal
go home see my family
uh yeah jf blaze the uh cyberpunk stream
will be tomorrow
we've had to figure out the time the
time has had to change
uh no i will not be playing halo with
chat no i will play this with chat
it's on pc um though the game is also on
switch playstation 4 and xbox one
apparently since it's released on
september 10th the game has been
downloaded more than half a million
times
it's a number of downloads but i am i am
on pc i am on my
streaming account which means that the
name is just charlana's odd and it's
publicly available to everyone so
if you want but we'd have to have a
bunch of you do it so that we could
follow lobbyists the thing
um so let me know if you do that
i don't know if it's cross-platform i
sadly don't think it is but i'm not sure
i'm not positive
but i feel like this would be a really
fun game to
play with people so yeah if y'all can on
pc let me know if you own it i'm not
gonna
ever tell anyone to you know buy a thing
so ah kevin i love project gotham
raising
so good thank you allocat i appreciate
that
yeah that was a streamful of a lot of
people that i did not know obviously i
know aoc
um
it's very weird to be part of like a
cultural event like that but still very
cool
uh and also i asked if she was single so
that happened that did happen
technically as a joke
but still
kayla okay i don't know that being a
switch owner is that tough
i feel like you chose pretty well the
nintendo switch ladies and gentlemen
great console great console um
okay we could play this again what else
do i have to tell you there is a note
here saying featuring tracks and
playfully reimagined locations from
across the globe i was right
san francisco confirmed uh drivers but
this thing with personality i agree with
that an easy to pick up yet hard to
master drift centric gameplay i feel
like i also agree with that
i didn't pick it up immediately this
retro arcade racer is available with
xbox game pass there you go for everyone
who asked it is on xbox game pass
maybe i should have played it on xbox
because then i could have you guys join
me so easily how does that sound
should i swap over
if i swapped to to xbox and then people
would just send me a message then i can
enjoy new to the game
and i imagine it's a pretty quick
download eh
obviously i gotta i gotta keep playing
it but uh
i don't think that would be difficult
for me to do
at the same time is all i'm saying
okay let's do a different game mode what
is this evade the cops and make off with
the money to take down the robbers okay
uh how to choose different oh i probably
need to unlock stuff
we can do the tour we can start with the
tour let's do this first
um dookie mookie
it does have cosplay are you sure
i feel like it would still be easier for
me to to organize on xbox though
i might swap to manual once i get
automatic down um
that was uh yeah i already streamed on
twitch today doing this one on youtube
because this is a sponsor stream there
is a part of me that is
toying with partnering on twitch
um i've not wanted to do it like i've
really not wanted to do it
because i don't like platform
exclusivity and i don't want to buy into
that i just think it sucks um
and i also like have had this youtube
audience because i've had this channel
for like almost a decade and i think it
sucks to like tell people to go to a
different place however
the youtube chat is harder to moderate
and can sometimes just be flooded with
trolls so
i don't know i'm thinking about it and i
feel like i will only partner on twitch
if i can figure out a way that i could
use any money that comes from that
because i currently don't really make
any money from streaming
which i'm fine with you know it's not my
job um
i don't know which one i am didn't i
pick cops oh no i do grand prix that's
right i was like am i a cop or a robber
disregard oh gosh that was bad that all
of that was bad we don't feel good about
any of that
um if i could figure out something
useful to do with that money so like
something to donate it to or
something to put it towards because i
don't want to
pocket it it doesn't feel right
uh but we'll see i don't know i haven't
made any decisions on that
mike back again okay um the drifting is
getting easier
that was way too far i can i can
definitely get a lot better at it this
is not something that you're going to
master
immediately you know
i just got a notification for that
distracted me that was your fault
dr bananas474 for following me on xbox
okay that was not my fault
is it has anyone confirmed if it's cross
play because i still feel like i should
jump over to
xbox because that's the easiest platform
for me to invite people on
which is why it's really the only place
i have a public account
for the record i have private accounts
on absolutely everything else
um aside from the ones that i use for
streaming
[Music]
such as the steam uh but it's so easy to
have someone message you and then you
just
directly inviting the game through the
menus
so
and they can follow you you don't have
to do ads and such
it's great i'm a fan
now we've got to figure out how to make
that tighter that's what she said
it is not cross play gotcha
roger that not my finest work but we
will take it it's fine
it's fine oh thank you shane
i appreciate you don't apologize for
being late certainly don't have to
apologize for being late
no worries there so what should i do
should i
should i download it on xbox i'm just
gonna do it
and then i would have to reset up some
stuff so i don't know
i don't know
king killer azoth i have already spoken
to twitch about being able to stream on
youtube as well
i am not allowed to
everyone is allowed to do exactly what
harris heller does there by the way you
only can't stream at both platforms at
the same time
how can you join on pc is a good
question i don't know um i think we
would have to matchmake and find each
other hopefully we can try i can try
right now if anyone's in here
i don't think that you can um
that you can co-stream even if you're uh
affiliate uh all right i need to
continue
but then we can i will try match make on
pc and we'll see if it happens we'll see
if enough people are in here
am i still going to make videos
certainly
i hope to decrease the amount of videos
that i'm making because right now i am
very overwhelmed um obviously staying on
top of work at
santa monica studios number one priority
and that's going just fine but the stuff
i have to do outside of work right now
is
a bit much for me so i need to decrease
that
ah nope
all right marcus i'm not out here trying
to ride mans
um but i hope that
to always have at least two a week and i
think it's possible
um shouldn't be any issue with that but
right now it's like multiple a day
it's like two a day i don't think this
is too many i can't keep doing this
it's too much i will but out and die
what i've actually been doing is not
working out as much which
is very important for my health
naturally i'm lost right now marcus i
blame you for that gun
also just not really playing
they might be too far ahead for me to
even catch up here which is a real
problem
we okay no i see
it should be all right that was good i
feel good about that
this is certainly very different to
forza
worth noting which i have played the
most of
but yeah when we finish the grand prix i
will match make on pc and we can see if
we can get that to work
otherwise i can just download the game
on xbox because it is on game pass
you love to see it i'm gonna lose this
race you
sons of jerks
you big old bunch of dweebs
i feel good about it though we're
learning okay so
we're learning and we're catching up
nope nope nope nope that sucked that was
no
it doesn't matter that we're catching up
either apparently because that was the
final lap
you hate to see it what's the stream at
some point i've already uh got a bunch
of forza gameplay on my channel actually
that's a good question carlos how do i
choose which games that i stream and
which ones that i play privately
um i generally only ever stream the
beginning of something and i very rarely
stream something i haven't played before
um it is actually less about what games
i stream and more about
um wanting to stream at a certain time
so like if i'm like well i've been
talking about how excited i am about
miles morales for a really long time
i should stream the opening of miles
morales um i mostly play video games
privately obviously
it's not looking great for me it's not
looking great
uh nick i'm not allowed to talk about
that but um i have a bigger impact than
that for sure
but uh i can't talk about my job
it looks a little lego-ish i think it's
kind of supposed to yeah
it's uh marcus you causing me beef again
dude what the hell
man
get out of here what is this
that one map from the mario kart 64.
jungle some of that was called the one
where you if you go up to
two that wasn't good the one where if
you go off the track you get hit with
the
the things from the trees i don't
remember the name of like any of the
implements
this is bad um i'm not doing good
okay time extended
uh i've said this a bunch before but
the first game i ever played
hey man was that marcus again
that's not fair i i'm uh he's done me
again mate
um oh it's actually that the physics are
different on the ground that's why i was
having trouble
first game i ever played was
motor racer which actually is an arcade
racer
um at least we're pretty sure my family
doesn't entirely knock because i've been
playing
video games since i could talk but uh
it might have been this educational game
but i don't know the name of
um where all i know is that it's maths
based
and a character says we like our eggs
scrambled
but that's all i can remember about that
game
am i catching up anybody's guess who
knows also
seriously where is this what is this
cool as hell place
if my donkey kong guess is wrong
i'm not allowed to answer that question
daniel you all got to stop
asking though i respect that nobody's
asking anything
inappropriate you're totally fine but
i'm not allowed to talk about it
okay
no i didn't no i didn't stop getting
distracted play the arcade racer
properly son
i also think that i keep expecting to be
able to chain my drifts like i can in uh
in the modern mario karts but that is
certainly not the case
see that felt a bit better if i'm paying
more attention
it does feel pretty good
do you get a boost from drifting like
you do
in your mark see again i keep getting so
close and then losing not great not
great
uh how do i boost brian i'm not sure how
to do it i get that you guys did
screaming use boost
hey thank you appreciate that i did not
know there was one
great question emily i have not yet
tried ring fit for working out
but um i did buy it the other day
because uh
i had issues with my oculus should be
getting a new one but um
okay stop yelling okay you spamming use
your boost in all caps is not gonna make
me do it anymore i didn't know it
existed all right please calm down
um yeah so i bought ring fit but i
haven't i haven't done it yet and i'm
waiting on getting a new oculus so that
i can work out with that too but
thank you dodo i appreciate that
i don't think i'll stream all miles
morales um i'm definitely gonna finish
that game but
because it hurt my wrist so much
i don't think it's a game i want to
stream because it just like
a adds pressure and b is painful and
when you're streaming you
uh it's harder to rationalize
taking breaks or like doing stupid side
quests that don't require combat so
that is probably not a game i will
stream more of
just because i have trouble playing it
due to wrist issues
and it not quite having enough
accessibility options for me which is a
real bomber
but can't play anything button mashy
really anymore which you know maybe i
can like get to a point where that game
doesn't
have any um button mashy effects for me
oh that's right you told me boost is a
oh that's gonna make this so much easier
are you kidding
no okay so we got a boost out of corners
is what we're gonna do
i could have been doing that this whole
time
whoa whoa wait wait this is that short
no stop it stop stop
stop that was rude that was rude from
all of you
also can they boost i genuinely don't
know
they don't seem to be boosting
big drift big boy drifts let's go
am i is my character getting sassy here
is that what's happening
okay the boost is a lot it is a lot more
powerful than i
initially gave it credit for you got to
watch that
am i building up boost by drifting is
that what's happening
hmm
i'm actually not sure it i think it is
i see hey man hey both of you get
that's not i can't build it up if you do
that to me
get out of my way man
[Music]
oh no oh heck
well okay so close a significant
improvement we'll take it
are they boosting i don't know i
genuinely don't know
again good to know boosting exists
this see now all especially feels unfair
because i didn't know the mechanic
was there that's i don't think that that
was deserved at all
none of it
i didn't notice any rubber banding pat i
haven't had an issue with that
um should i try multiplayer or any of
you here
should i should i do it will i be live
streaming cyberpunk almost definitely
you got on an xbox ah let me just pull
it up
uh that's not plugged in right now i
would have to change my settings if
enough of you do it i'm down too but
um that's what i was going to test is if
anyone is playing on
right see
and then in theory if anyone is playing
you would be able to find my game
i think if anyone's on pc is anyone
though that's the question i have
yeah i've got it on xbox how hard would
it be i just think it's
my elgato just plugged into my ps5 right
now it wouldn't be terribly hard for me
to change everything
all right let me let me change it so i
can play with you guys we can make it
happen
give me a second
it's actually the cyberpunk xbox so
that's cool
okay
here
great music though i'm a fan
um whatever you want to do here you
should just automatically work
obs did not like that that's not good
uh oh
i have no idea if you guys can still
hear me
because my obs just crashed
oh you can still hear me oh that's
strange well i guess you just wait for
obs to fix itself
how weird
you can see my camera i imagine i'm
frozen
right or is everything does everything
just look fine
huh
it well i
i think i just kind of have to wait for
obs to unfreeze
because i look frozen to myself
but you're gonna come through for me
it could crash at any minute you guys
and if it does i will just immediately
come back
i don't know why it happened i can set
up the xbox in the meantime though
connect to xbox live yes
it's still here it's so weird like
how am i streaming if obs is not
responding that doesn't make sense
that's so weird oh man
um okay
ah we can do that there's an update on
my xbox but it's only 560
megabytes easy
i the problem is i don't want to close
obs
because i don't want it to stop the
stream and i'm worried that if i close
obvious
then the stream is completely gone how
about if i close the game
and now you should
just have i think a black screen right
i think
uh can i open second no that's not gonna
work
that's not gonna work um
well i should still be here but the
game's probably black now correct
yeah okay and that my logic is that
maybe that will like
maybe that will make obs get its [ __ ]
together it does say i have four
instances of obs
open but you are working and i know you
are stop
lying to me there are people responding
to what i'm saying obs you
liar stop lying
and task ah aha
i fixed it all right
beautiful and it's still working for you
guys right
beautiful okay
cancel that close that
re-add the elgato
video capture device okay
no elgato game capture hd yes
and then we put that below that
and we make sure it works and then we
rename it
gotta do all of these things
um where is that there we go
beautiful ah everything's coming
together
not a problem and i just gotta update it
obviously
sound is gonna be this one i love this
monitor so much it's so good
all right well hi everyone
how are you guys doing you know we're
just updating
it's not a problem um
i'll just wait for it to to work
but in the meantime
i've never had obs crash like that
before
new experiences across the board
it is updating a lot slower than it
should be but there's there's been
something wrong with my wifi all day
like this should not be this slow this
is such a small update
uh i wonder what if there's a solution
to that
because this could end up being forever
and then the game could also take i can
just do both but i don't know why it's
taking so long
if you mix over obs are you kidding do i
think jake paul will win the fight
uh i don't know who is jake paul
fighting
uh my pc is hardwired this xbox is not
hardwired one of my other xboxes is and
my ps5 is but
i don't have that many connections for
all of my xboxes
there are way too many um this is also
not a new xbox this is the cyberpunk
xbox one x
that i um unboxed
see mike i have tested my internet and
it seems like my speeds are fine but
i've had trouble like loading pages and
stuff
pretty much all day so i have no idea
what's been happening i feel like what
i'm going to do is just we can just
continue playing the game
on pc and hope it doesn't crash my obs
again for no reason
and that should not be a problem
um and then i can swap over in a little
bit it is gonna be really small though
i the stress i'm putting on this monitor
by doing this my gosh okay
let's see if i can get this to work here
we go hot shot racing
yes done
we gotta get rid of that that and that
that's my mic that's fine desktop is
fine
we do this okay
yup this is wild
i i wish i could show you what what this
looks like this setup and then sound i
have to swap back over
to sound source here
okay progress is being made
okay
hmm
a problem has presented itself i think
that i might have to
race within the obs window
okay i can do it it's gonna be really
small i can do it i can make it happen
and i'll also have myself
visible so that's gonna be a problem but
we can make it work
nick h what's my thing to write my
favorite everything that i've written
actually aside from a few fantasy novels
has been sci-fi
by accident um it's just the themes
i've always found the most compelling
but i've also written a couple of
romantic things which
you know always bleed into horror i've
never done straight romance um but i
read more fantasy than anything else
all right ah this is gonna be this could
be tough
it's gonna be real tough we'll make it
make it work this is plugged into the
xbox right now
all right okay
the xbox just updated
no surface headphones work with xbox was
thinking about getting better you like
them i love them
i don't know if they work with xbox um
the way that i have my sound routed is
that my
headphones are plugged directly into my
monitor
not to my xbox and then my xbox is
is hdmi into my monitor so um
that's the output so i actually don't
know but i imagine they do i love them i
think they're fantastic
what life path am i in cyberpunk i'm
nomad
was i playing this game on pc through
game pass no which i guess i could have
done
but xbox is still the easier ui um no
i'm playing this on steam
i'm not going to tell you what my right
up pseudonym would be i said [ __ ] on
him
just suiting him
it's good tea well i'm not a street kid
brad because i'm not in street kid
my character is only available in nomad
so that's a thing i would like to see
myself naturally
all right i just have to change the
controller over
i have so many controllers here surely i
can just pull another one out i can of
course i can
who am i kidding where did i put that
here we go
just handy controllers everywhere
and then i need the cable for you
this one this one
which is not a great cable you have to
be for this video
but it will work also in case you're
wondering what it looks like
australian money i keep in this draw
50 australian dollars little see-through
window down here
it's got people on it
see how pretty they are also it's it's
all plasticky
and then we have a tendon
isn't it beautiful isn't it
i think it's great shout out to
australia might
okay let me plug in this controller
my console is at 84 but the game could
take forever to download because my
internet
i think what's happened is that i'm
capped because i've done too many
streams this week
um all i can deduce from that is that my
internet provider hates charity so
take it up with them
did i do it i think i did it i find it
so funny
if you look at my streams compared to
like professional streaming streams
it's just the difference okay
video game why are you blurring me
that's i feel censored i i
don't know why that's happened okay here
we go put that over there
oh this is such a challenge this setup
is such a challenge
okay that is what i need to do
oh geez how am i gonna do this
i think i have to close the game window
right and then usb device is not
recognized
damn you okay that's not gonna work
the things i do i tell you i tell you
uh yes my split is screen in half my
split is screen
my screen is split in half patrick yeah
that is how i do it
um i love it again that's why the super
ultra wide monitor is the best because i
have the xbox here
pc here same screen
um but because of that
my pc screen is in 1080 right now rather
than being full screen and i'm not
figuring out how to fix that yet
um the paneling but uh that means that
the game
it's complicated
okay
figured it out we got it we got it we
got it i still have to watch myself
though i can't play the game on the full
screen by itself
but now again you know
wait did i not get that i don't wanna do
the same one
i'm gonna do it on normal and i'm gonna
go as caco
hell yes
i still i
i think i'm going to go with this one
all right again i'm going to have to
look at my own self
as an obstacle while playing this
because of the way that i've set it up
um yes g4 is making a comeback
um they did do a costing poll with me
even though i was like hey guys just so
you know
i would not quit my job for this as well
it was still a fun house
um because g4 is not
this is such a funny way to play this um
not really a thing
that is well known in australia
um didn't didn't have any of that
nostalgia for me and i've also just done
that kind of work for so long that that
i didn't see it as
um a hugely beneficial opportunity and
anyway to work for them full time
um however i would be open to
collaborating they did ask me to do some
charity stuff for them this week
i did uh help out on a stream today for
them
i was gonna host a thing for them on
tuesday but was way too busy
um but yes when they initially
approached me i was very direct in
saying
i will not do this full time just so you
guys
i think they've announced xavier woods
as their first
actual host which is super cool i really
like him austin creed it's a really
great i'm forgetting to boost again
um he's a really fun dude
i definitely
credit this game for uh
[Music]
the actual genuine requirement
in in getting to know it not something
that you can just master immediately for
sure
i also think that's probably a strat to
be had with where you want to use your
boosts i think someone did say use them
all at the end that's a pretty good idea
get out of here dude like if i had a
boost right now
they'll be tight but i don't
okay now i do and we're gonna save it
we didn't save it alana you got so
tempted by just overtaking that one dude
that you threw the boost
i think i'm gonna be fine anyway
okay i have to swap this controller over
again so i can download the game
hot shot racing
nope oh a way out i'm absolver ace
combat
skies agonus that looks cool whatever
that is
okay here we go hot shot racing big boss
bundle install son
put it to the top of the queue
we don't need to update apex over here
that's fine i have that updated
elsewhere
50 gigs apex no no that's not happening
for us today
um oh this is downloading quickly so
yeah if you guys want to play with me
which is what we're setting up right now
uh it would be find me on xbox which is
char
lanazad hit me with a follow i don't
even know if you actually have to do
that you would just have to message me
that you're playing the game
so that then i can invite you to the
game um
which would work out real well
i can see that being a thing joe who
just said it takes a while to get used
to
streaming is definitely never the ideal
way to get used to something however
i like this game a lot uh even based on
the small amount that i've played i did
play a little bit full stream but
it is not cross-platform so i am
downloading on xbox
it should be done in about four minutes
apparently
and then you guys who are on xbox can
play with me which is just kind of the
easiest way to do it
sadly i think it's gotten easier on
playstation there was an issue for a
while where people had to add to you
but i don't think you need to do that
now i know they they made the following
system for a few people but i also try
to keep my playstation accounts like
pretty private i've been streaming from
one which is
a new account that i pretty much just
made
um because i like having private
accounts and everything
[Music]
uh this microphone is a roadie pro costa
yes rick yes do it i did put oow in the
title yeah
i really did yeah
we are two gigabytes down we're gonna
get there it's gonna happen
you guys just gotta wait for me to
finish downloading the thing
watch how long of hook what is that uh
rick i have already spoken about that
but yeah i will
absolutely play snowman i'm already
playing a mortals phoenix rising
bluefire legacy i don't think we'll
talk about it yet though
it would be cool if you could have
discord voice chat on on consoles yeah
for cosplay stuff that would be really
neat
have i found a partner through that new
dating app among us dead chat
one of my favorite things to do i find
this so much funnier than i think anyone
else finds it
um so i hit on people in the chat of
every single game of all of them
um and in uh
runescape which is a game that i have
played a fair amount of um
i will be like hey
um blonde girl living in cali
27 um anyone want to meet up and i find
it hilarious because i'm telling the
truth but of course nobody will think
i'm telling the truth
that's my favorite uh yes those
notifications are messages for uh for
xbox yeah
but anyway i find it really funny
because it's like the idea that i'm
telling 100 the truth and
if anyone ever bit like they'd get to
like like we'd just chat about it and be
like no really i am a 27 year old blonde
girl living in california that is all of
that is true
but no one ever responds to me because
they assume that i'm lying and it's so
funny to me
i don't know why
or they just don't care they're just out
there trying to question that that's
also entirely possible so
that could be a thing too but the bait
is real that's the point it's real
bait it's so good
it's true patrick it's true runescape is
very old kayla you are not wrong but
also i absolutely love it so
uh rick where are you you can probably
download cyberpunk early if you are in a
certain region
yeah maybe bonds aren't the hot thing
anymore or maybe they know that it's not
true blonde it's more of a silver
they're like you're not even blonde you
liar
and apparently having silverish hair
makes you like some kind of
sjw cuck or something
that's my point i don't think it's bait
because it's real and i'm telling the
truth
um let me to give you guys an update on
how this is going real quick
oh got him there we go
return desktop audio off i'll leave it
for now
and then we'll turn our got it on put it
down a bit
and this should all work out beautifully
i'm excited i
i feel like there aren't often that many
games that i stream that i can play
multiplayer so
hopefully this goes smoothly and i think
this game is really fun
[Music]
make sure that the elgato sound is
working
it currently is good good good yes yes
yes
yes accident i'm gonna have to it's
gonna be delayed so i'm gonna have to
delay my mic for a second
[Music]
hey am i talking with a delay
i should be it should
be sounding off sink filters
and we go render delay and now it should
match
okay i haven't played my spider-man yet
um but soon
excuse me
we're doing it okay so now i'm going to
turn it off on pc
i'm gonna change my mic source
i mean my audio source input select
system setup
sound sound source done
okay i think we're on a roll
oh thank you jess
oh that's interesting i actually didn't
know that sorry they said uh given your
appreciation for stadia appreciation's a
strong word
but um interest in is what i would say i
have
uh and it has worked for me but i don't
know that i would say appreciate it
however
um she said it might be worth mentioning
that if you pre-order seven point three
stated you get cyberpunk
premiere edition um that's cool okay
we've done it we've got video game
and now hopefully there are enough of
you that we can fill a lobby
that's part two
okay online postgame
um i still don't know how to change the
okay
sounds cool to me
i think that's probably the way i should
do it
and then we have to go
this way
i don't know what my messages say
currently so i'm just going to
make this disappear real quick so that i
can make sure
oh you wouldn't see them anyway would
you yeah they're in chats they're
separate
and for the record what i've just hidden
is not anything that anyone should be
suspicious of i am protecting someone
bad
okay i'm gonna go with whoever asked
first
nope are you available
um this is going to be more
invite do i have to invite you to party
unclear view profile and then i think i
can go
invite to a game
i think that will work eh
i think this is the way to do it no no
no this one
invite to a game right
i think i'm doing this correctly
[Music]
invite to a game success we have someone
yay
this is great i'm very happy this is
working
okay
cool
your uh microphones will be broadcasted
for the record but
uh i will only be able to talk to you on
the stream because mine is not
in here by two again
and that's it right are we full i don't
know we'll just see who fills it up i
guess
this is definitely too many people but
we'll just keep going
hello cyber mates am i to the game
that's surely got to be it
surely
it's full now i think maybe
is it
yeah i think it is or at the very least
we can't invite everyone people um
okay
that would be none
okay we did it oh my gosh we did it
it's happening
[Music]
i'm excited
uh i honestly [ __ ] props to game pass
obviously uh full disclosure i like
something
um for making things like this so doable
so easily you know
[Music]
and also thank you to hotchat racing for
sponsoring the stream so we could do
something cool like this
hope none of your pros i'm gonna get
cleaned up
we'll see we'll see what is this blur
sorry matt i'm so sorry i'm really sorry
about it i didn't mean
i didn't mean to disrespect you like
that it was a complete accident
who do you think you are chucks who do
you think you are ooh that's a much
bigger corner than i thought it was
i feel okay if there's anything that's
different about playing with real people
over ai
that we are just smashing into each
other constantly
damn
[Music]
wow wow wow that's a lot that's a lot
[Music]
that's a straight so we're gonna boost
on it
how did you just do that but i boosted
how did you out boost me
we had the exact same path though
my strat was good oh thank you i will
take the achievement thank you
[Music]
all i'm saying here is you guys we've
had technical difficulties to stream
you know all that good stuff but the
vibes are good
i like the vibes also how's the audio is
the game too loud i guess i can't read
chat while racing but you'll
be able to let me know any minute now
get off my ass
what me no
oh that's not fair that was so unfair
i would have got a second we'll take it
though we'll take it though
it's all good thank you guys um
i will rotate people in and out i will
stick with this group for a few more and
then we'll just like jump people in and
if anyone leaves i'll jump someone else
in so that a lot of people can get a
chance to play
you telling me they're gonna be some
easy chibis here i don't mind if i do
so hopefully it keeps the lobby
otherwise i don't have to reinvite
people every time we don't have to okay
let's just can i do like a
now i'll stick to arcade okay
sure why not
and let's go another lap shall we
sweet hi matt
i don't have a microphone to talk to you
guys but technically if you talk to me i
will hear it
you are welcome to do so if you would
like to
but everyone on the stream will also
hear it
the butta beanie oh my god
cars can be cosmetically customized
thanks for the for the hot tip
i appreciate that
i keep thinking it's sunday because
we've had those day through friday off
and i have really screwed up this long
weekend
by sleeping way too much um
which is very much a part of my dna but
also
makes me miserable when it's winter
because it's too dark up
just bums me the [ __ ] out
but i keep panicking because i'm like
[ __ ]
oh no but uh i don't i have a whole
extra day to clean my apartment
which is all i'm really going to do
i got boosts i should use them
chuck's out here in the front again
look at you go
[Music]
this is not good alana but you can boost
on recovery there
oh my gosh well that the collision like
what happens as a result of you smashing
into someone is
very hectic
i love that love a good
i was just saying that i liked something
this is how you repay me
this i can't even tell which way i'm
supposed to go that was the worst thing
that's ever happened to me in my entire
life
um and you should all feel really bad
about it
i can't the disrespect i make this lobby
i invite you my seventh closest friends
and this is what you do the audacity
to beat me up like that in my own lobby
oh my gosh
i don't know if i can recover from it
well not when you do that alana not when
you
do that
why did i give up on it that was stupid
why didn't i commit to the drift
you know wait wait are we all the same
character why are there so many
blonde dudes in here it was
i think that's the one woman maybe yeah
that's the american woman adds because
she's default
that's why
i love the achievers bro love them love
this catch-up
feeling good about it sorry about that
so many mats i did not mean
to hit you just now or then
either of them honestly i didn't mean to
um just giving myself props for the
recovery is all
which you are significantly hurting now
okay but
ah that was close
[Laughter]
everyone was very rude everyone was very
rude
is my webcam too big it is a lot bigger
than it normally is i don't know
do i have a contingency plan in case
cyberpunk 2077 flops
why would i need a contingency plan why
would i
care um
obviously i don't want any game to flop
and you know they're a very hard walking
team
but why would i need a plan for that
that doesn't make sense
dude
i wasn't sure if there was like a boost
on start timing and there probably is
because it's an arcade racer but i
actually don't know what it is is the
problem but it wasn't whatever i just
did
let me tell you that much well that
wasn't good
i appreciate that thank you
[Music]
okay okay okay hey what the hell oh
that's right
you have boosts and have used them so
what's happened there
this is a very cool map and i'm a big
fan of it
hey why are you out here killing good
vibes man
just don't understand wow the chaos that
just went down in front of me
[Music]
that is the strat that i like to play is
use boost to recover
um in other exciting news my coolant
leaked
today not from my pc but from my
bottle of coolant which i had on a
drawer
so i had to clean out the entire drawer
um do some minor damage repair on the
damage that i did to that draw
by virtue of coolant leaking in it
out of nowhere i don't even know how it
happens
pc gaming is exciting
uh i basically had to like like pimples
pop these like little holes in the
[ __ ] wood um to get the coolant out
so
it was very exciting i love a wild list
how many laps are we on and we're fine
everyone's actually pretty close
together this time
ish
and i do feel like i'm improving at the
drifting so
i will take that
hey man
oh my god
it's just so funny watching people speed
past you because you all have the same
i love it though this video is possible
but here's the thing with any sponsored
content again
super rude that's me done again um any
sponsor content i do i only have to do
stuff that i actually like
or i'm interested in i cannot believe
the robbery that just occurred don't
think i can recover
i can't devastating
absolutely devastating
not fair at all
didn't deserve any of it
my fault it's close
i unlocked customization items all right
wait did i just hit quit i think that's
fine i think that's fine
but i wouldn't mind
[Music]
it's this one that i want to use i'm
going to modify it
oh i like that okay
i know i like my car in one
yes
yes i didn't even really think about it
ah
well that's what i'd want because they
look like bbrs
[Music]
i want that too how much is that two
grand we just gotta get two grand boot
huh i have no money can i change the
column
interesting okay
that's cute i'm gonna go with this one
beautiful beautiful beautiful beautiful
starfire
i'm a fan great cool okay let's go
um
[Music]
let's do it let's do it
yeah they don't have vastly different
specs from what i can tell the costs
don't have like hugely different specs
but they do have different specs
and i like it um i will play
one more race with these folk and then i
will have to kick some to boot some new
people in
[Applause]
i'm gonna keep it in yellow what's the
plan
ah beautiful i got the achievement for
it
i [ __ ] my start hell yeah
oh no that was actually just being
customized you got it
ready getting fun out of my face man
oh vegas bangby
dollar rude
if i could stop dancing i might have
better plays that's all i'm saying whoa
didn't expect that to be that sharp oh
my gosh oh my gosh it's like mario kart
oh no
no no that was intense and terrible
oh gosh it's okay
it being on the first lap that doesn't
really matter
you're going to be just fine
all right
i fell through the world i boosted
through the entire world and then i
drifted on the two barriers
so far behind it's just it just it never
feels fair but when it happens multiple
times in a row it has to be my own fault
it just doesn't feel like it is am i in
[Music]
denial
you know what i'm saying
come on this is the sharp one not that
sharp this time
didn't have that much problem with it
actually
if i can just catch up to you at least
stop with that corner i wanna stupid
dummy and big stupid dummy
not your finest
[Applause]
i like this map i think i might say that
about everyone though
is that even english
[Music]
in here
we're still really far behind
yeah i don't think recovery is going to
happen no again on that corner
okay well i'll take you that i'm all
right
oh you lose drift if you hit walls
oh my gosh
i don't think it's gonna happen i don't
think the recovery is possible for me
yeah
that's all i'm saying
you do lose boost
[Applause]
no i slowed down so much because i was
so scared of
taking damage that it just screwed me
over anyway
damn it always backwards that's me
that's me and lost
just couldn't recover just couldn't we
just couldn't do it like how it was an
airborne perhaps
that was great that was great it was
impossible impossible
i did fall through the map
oh thank you to the person who donated
the one hundred thousand dollars not
quite how that works but i appreciate it
thank you
um all right i gotta kick some of these
people out thank you all for playing
with me
but we gotta start again i may reinvite
some of you i don't know we'll see
um i'm gonna do this and we are going to
do
that one can i increase the max play
account
it has to be eight um
why don't we do the barrel barrage
create and then i just go invite
no that's right has to be this way
chat quests i'm gonna go down to the
bottom
uh-huh oh i haven't missed anyone at the
bottom i don't think i have
invite are you playing minecraft right
now
[Music]
uh uneven game is gone man you gotta fix
that you gotta fix them tings
yeah i do okay you got dc
and by too gay
amazing okay
i just keep doing it i just keep doing
it
what does the green do i don't know why
some of us are green and some of us
are not
i really am just spamming invites
but we'll just keep going until it fills
up
how many two more i think one more
this would probably be the last one
i feel like this will be getting filled
i could anyway just see what happens
okay stop
okay cool let's go hopefully these
people aren't as rude
you know what i'm saying anyway
i don't know how long i've been
streaming for i have no concept of that
thank you for joining me to the people
who played round one i appreciate it
i can hear myself in your stream rick
just so you're aware
[Applause]
it's a zoo
[Music]
[Applause]
it's okay it's right the dude who dm'd
me
saying gotta do it on one was wrong
this is so cute
does anybody know what barrel barrage is
oh um
so you get barrels that you
hold i think it's b to drop and it will
explode other people on the track
is the answer to that question if you
happen to be listening to the stream so
it's like you have uh mario kart shells
i feel like i got someone there i don't
think i might have
i felt like there was an explosion right
behind me
solid unit probably has one just hasn't
used it
yet you could go
[Music]
nope
that might have been my first one you
know
ah oh i didn't get me somehow i don't
know how that even happened
oh your car's on fire mate it's not
looking good for you out here
so that's one person like i think
completely kicked out of the race now
oh we all have health bars well i feel
like i'm doing pretty good on health
i'll say that much
[Music]
i sure did fam i sure did
here on fire got risks coming
oh that was unlucky is game chat working
can you give anybody messages it is yes
let me know
that'll be cool
[Music]
but i really like it
i was waiting for that dude to just drop
a barrel in my face for sure see i just
turned it off turned on youtube saw a
lot of playing i'm like okay
i took a lot of risks that i shouldn't
have taken and now i'm just driving real
slow
oh god oh god oh god oh god
no
we're gonna take this fiery win jesus
oh win
[Music]
oh so is it last person alive is that
how that works
i thought it was but it is not somebody
just finished the race i did yes
somebody wherever charlotte hennes are
wow cleaning up game is called love to
see it
thank you sam that's a good pun i wasn't
like zero health that was intense
um okay let's choose another one
i don't know what i've done anymore surf
city
[Music]
oh is there an ai player in here i think
there is
oh well um
plays this game you can add me and i
will play
hey anyone watching the stream would
like to add rick 330.
i always i try not to say positive
things about sponsored games which like
it's probably something i enjoy two or
three honest
that was fun but um
just not to create the impression but
this game is super
and now i'm going to achieve my money so
that's me
[Applause]
super rude there right off the corner
i was too careful
that's the ai get out of here what are
you doing
that's not fair at all
how dare you
i cannot believe this ai get your butt
out of here
oh somebody already bought up oh no no
no no no no
taking hits taking heads take a heads
i'm losing so much health by hitting
other cars
nope don't feel good about how this is
going
here we go
oh did we just miss that i think maybe
police probably had it
[Applause]
hey get out of one way
i don't think that worked the way i
planned for it to that would have been
rough
uh-uh just keep it walls
this ai is too good it is
unreasonable [ __ ]
we are taking hits we're taking hits
get away from all
i do still have health though so
happy about that oh another one exploded
look at them all right here
everybody stress panel
[Applause]
okay
oh [ __ ]
i'm gonna blame myself for some of those
barrels so i can't even be mad about the
placement
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh i cannot believe the ai beat me just
then that's so mean
that's a good race there but very very
[Music]
neat
a lot of explosions on that one because
all the turns is what i think happened
oh thank you chase i appreciate that um
okay let's invite
another person shall we this way is the
easier way to do it
channel quests go down sure
oh i know scotty hawkeye
oh guys you got to use the f1 car that's
just nasty i accidentally continued
uh marcus is my favorite i didn't mean
to do that i'll do it on the next one
i'm sorry that's my bad
what happens i don't understand what
just happened
[Music]
okay
[Music]
complete accident but it is no matter
i use marcus because his
indoor his when you're in the car did i
like select a tournament is that what i
mean i don't know
it's not like that's right
i hate when you do an entire view and
you can barely see the
environment so that's why i like
marcus's car
oh that was rough to watch i should have
killed someone
for sure
okay hey
hey now who do you think you are
[Laughter]
no that was the ai that just got taken
out hard and i
am low on health we are not going to
finish this
i don't know talking about that drink
though not about that one
i just pressed the wrong button that
time oh oh no
i am on fire stop telling me to blow
someone up i'm just trying to get my
health back
big jack which is one of these
[Applause]
nope
[Music]
i don't know how i got so much worse
this race oh my god okay i'll add to
that
[Applause]
ridiculous okay
[Applause]
a lot of has a lot of help do i it's
right in front of me
i'm panicked i feel like i have no
health
i'm just hitting everything and boosting
it bad times
okay i guess i'll do pasta that matters
if you're that far in the lead and you
don't hit anyone you'll actually be fine
um
oh my gosh
i don't think there's anything i can do
oh i'm fine there she felt that i was
way further back okay that's actually
not so bad
on fire though
that was narrow it was really narrow
dude you can drop barrels the whole
thing all right we're gonna be fine
wait what can you do
you press b and you can drop um eddie
i'm doing it in order gosh i have no
idea
barrels i am picking whoever messaged me
first so it's basically an order
is the idea
nine thousand dollars oh my gosh
okay that ai i tell you
so this is where i have to do this
and i guess some of these people i will
have missed um like i don't know that i
ended up inviting
barrel barrage is not bad
and i like straight racing but that
should work i think um okay yeah i like
fireworks a whole lot
dude you gotta try the f1 might have
done that already it's so much better i
tried do i have the f1 i tried all the
cards
i oh i just like i don't know
i've actually played this game a lot
like i said the lobbies are just
horrible
never find anybody all right
[Music]
cool me
oh welcome let's
no i did surf city again no no no no no
no no no
we're doing desert
sure i've lost which ones i've done
which one i haven't done so
whatever
[Music]
you can modify the racer i think it's
colors i guess kayla i'm not actually
positive but that's what it seems to be
uh you can go first person i have not i
don't like playing first person in
really any racing game um
never have i think it
i'm just not used to it i don't know
i like this mount i like the i like the
volcano balls volcano balls
oh no
ah boost ruined
i think i have done this map already
though
okay yeah this car is pretty sweet
oh that's a nice drift oh that's real
nice
oh my gosh
wow this this yeah this is real tidy
it's very clean controls i didn't expect
that corner to do that
not my fault that was a rude one oh wow
okay
all right okay hot shot racing
here's the volcano balls didn't see it
coming
yeah this one's nice
got some nice corners in here
oh my gosh someone pooped out up here
all right
forgot you can do that yeah uh
beat a barrel just like that
[Applause]
oh someone already exploded damn it
alana damn it i want to stop hitting
walls
getting overwhelmed
i will i think he says that when you got
too stored
yeah that someone already exploded with
me
all right teammate oh no i just didn't
even
drift there
right in my face
it's not looking good fam it's not
looking good out here
is this the one that'll give me health
it is thank god
so many barrels everywhere and i'm just
gonna make it worse
look how much health this person in
front of me has
i feel like we're just making it very
hard for everyone who's further behind
six people left get out of here
i hope that that exploded on you
i just ran right into it it's like i
just
i didn't even try to avoid it i saw it
from far enough off and i was like well
i accept my demise so
that's what happened it do be like that
hold on i just watched it implode
you get zero dollars to die oh my gosh
hey thank you will phillips i intend to
continue to stream semi-frequently
and did another person drop out
um probably not as much as i have
leading up to this point but we will
certainly continue so i guess i've got
to invite another person i think i do
i think this person i already played i
look at all these gamer scores
everybody's got impressive stuff okay
they're in the menu so
hopefully that person joins
um i'll leave so you can fill someone
else in ggs thanks for the invite oh no
worries thank you
thanks for joining uh then let's do this
uh person said they got dc
i think you have already raced with us
though i will invite you again
there's no real method to this
particular kind of madness for the
record
just doing what i can there
and we'll try you again oh i think they
were only in one race
that's the person who's in like the
first one do that
just whoever gets in first is what it's
going to be
nope can't does that mean it's full
because it doesn't look like it is you
know what i'm saying do you know what i
am saying
yeah i can't for some reason i don't
know why
[Music]
let's do this shall we
and then maybe see if anybody wants for
some reason i don't know why it would
i don't know why what i'm trying i'm
trying scott
it's so hard to balance the audio so i
apologize if she comes through my mic
once in a great one you're fine
uh i guess we'll just go and then fix it
next round
do i need to pick what people are is
that what you're telling me
what have i done i see
okay cup cop cop
rubber rubber rubber
[Music]
i'm sorry scott i don't know why it
wouldn't let me invite you i don't know
what happens i genuinely don't i'll try
again though
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so i think that we have to yeah
just chase down the robbers is what the
situation is
all right other cop hot damn
all right cops and robbers i'm just
going to race because i don't know what
is going on
not a great turning circle on this as it
turns out as it were
pretty actually quite bad what is this
car made of
okay so we have to i do have to take
them down is that what the situation is
gonna be
oh my gosh the handling on this cupcake
is this what cops really have to deal
with
yikes bro
because it's a lot
oh one has already been taken down okay
well i didn't help but i'm glad you guys
are out here doing good work
fellow cops
so it is an easier car to drift in but
it's terrible regarding almost
everything
else she says something immediately
no it is easier
it's like it's pretty smooth and you can
pull out of it real fast
but that i have nowadays before am i
playing with myself because i do not see
anybody that
i've worded that wrong
bank school what does that mean
hello ai how are you doing you having
trouble driving this stupid car as well
because it's heavy
he sure is heavy
i just don't even i'm sure they are i
don't know what you want me to do
unclear on game mode
i think they're just kind of gonna win
and that his look his score is going up
by so much
wait okay so we got rid of one of the
robbers
we probably have to hit them right but
um
that probably means that i shouldn't be
using this like a race this is what i'm
thinking
that i should just wait right
so i'm gonna catch me
[Applause]
yeah yeah no i'm right and then go this
way is what i'm thinking
that was not the greatest way to do it
but i think i'm on to something
with this we're not supposed to be just
racing
don't know what that game mode is
so we're just not going to do it again
we're just not going to do it again
we're going to assign something else
um that everyone will understand because
it's hard to communicate with people
that you are not
actually talking to whoa okay and now
i'll see if i can invite more people in
again
maybe i don't know why it won't let me
ah now you got it scotty hawkeye you got
it
yeah i think it's it's maybe just having
to catch up to itself basically
and that should be that
i think we've done it oh my gosh we've
done it
beautiful what's wrong
i don't know what this is welcome
[Music]
scotty is in scotties and it's just nice
to play this game with a full audience
[Music]
i see i see i see i see
okay cool
slowing down under any circumstances got
it seems fine
okay this is kind of like the barrel
once without barrels
whatever that time
[Applause]
this is going to be an interesting
challenge
like that's
that's yeah i see
what does the time bomb do
because you gotta you gotta save your
boosts for when things are slow
basically is the idea
oh shoot soul unit knows what he's doing
scott already exploded
it got scary it got real scary
oh my gosh
oh the panic and it's this song
the song just has no chills
oh god oh god oh god oh god okay okay
okay
this one is definitely the most
stressful because i'm i'm
seconds away from exploding at all times
no come on come on
that's not going to last me much longer
though there's no way
i think this is it i think i'm done
[Music]
intense
good drips this the cinematic camera too
wow you guys are doing fine actually
yeah you're doing just fine um
zero dollars sweet to anyone who's just
joining us on the stream if you would
like to play
i know i have to go faster it's tough
though
um send me a message on xbox live
my username is charolanazone and just be
like yo down to play obviously you have
to have
hotshot racing installed it is on
gamepass so you can get it for free
also this is a sponsored video this
one's in stream rather
i'm just gonna i think we've done most
of those
um
and yeah i will cycle people through
it's pretty much the plant i'll probably
play for another half hour
um i could get off next i've won two
games in a row
thank you
all right scooterman gaming okay you
wanna all right
what are you you gonna come into my
lobby and that's how you're gonna treat
me
are you joking
the damage i am taking from expense of
other people
come on we need to mix this lobby up
it is interesting i like that mechanic
that whoever's in the lead is the one
who starts the time bomb
um
basically burning whoever's at the end
and the song gets faster every time this
is a really cool mode
um i don't think this is part of the new
dlc
to be fair
but it is cool
um i mean i should clarify that but
they're all free so this is not the new
dlc
yeah the new dlc barrel one that we did
correct and some loads and grand prix
ah
i'm trying to speed up man i'm trying
i'm trying
have we lost anyone yet i can't look i
can't take my eyes away from the screen
really on fire out here
this song it's so funny
i think we have lost someone
it might just be one though
i know i'm trying man i'm trying
[Music]
i don't know that this song can even get
any faster than it is right now
ooh another explosion do we get two more
explosions just now
oh wow i think it's just the three of us
then
we'll just say this four or two i don't
know
[Music]
i did just just play a dirty trick there
so if it didn't work i just have it
[Music]
keep hitting walls no matter what
hitting walls
oh no
come on come on come on come on come on
come on yeah
that was close
the winds give you so much money so much
money
i have been beaten oh gg
[Music]
yeah like i said i'm not a streamer or
anything but
i will play this game with people if
they want no dude thank you rick
anyone would like to add rick you could
do that that would be cool
thank you jared appreciate that means a
lot means a lot
um we'll see you guys bye rick i will
see you rick invite someone to see you
guys
in your place thank you
you sure can try again you sure can
there you go bubble butt
let's go did you get your mind walking
it sounds like you did
it's like being like one degree away
from aoc
technically
uh alexander wise it is also on the xbox
one yes
it sure is oh thank you um
so trying to get this person to join i
will invite someone else if i need to
i know we're making them be speedy
it is what it is john snow
pants
no i think that means a person's trying
to join i think maybe it's it's just
it uh just bugs out occasionally so
we'll just have to go ahead with it
and then it should fix next time
why is this happening
i'm unclear on why this is happening
what is bug what is issue
do you think that i don't have two plays
is that what the problem is i don't know
what i've done wrong
um okay it worked
cool
thank you davoiji i appreciate that
okay area 41 huh
i like this one it is fun
also just so lovely knowing how intense
this music actually does end up getting
considering how chill it is right now
it's so funny that's such a cool idea
um
did i miss that is that what just
happened i think i might have just
driven past it accidentally
[Applause]
no i think we're fine
it's already speedy
[Applause]
i'm going to find time out here though
diamond achievement you say oh cool
thanks
who i thanked it even though i
technically accomplished it myself
thank you xbox i really appreciate the
support
[Music]
oh is the max speed increasing every
time as well
um that's interesting
i'm not actually sure if it is it is
rough and there goes the song
that's why people start exploding at the
back it gets too fast
all right okay g unit
just be popping like that
i gotta stalk them i want to stop
wasting your speeds stop wasting them
whoa
damn dudes explode somebody's out
i think that is our first person out
there
you guys can't see the map i realize um
because my webcam is covering it but you
can see people's faces like
their avatar is just like flicker i'm
not even entirely sure why
[Music]
risky plays carolina what the music just
got to panic me every time
trying to try
we diffused the bomb ladies and
gentlemen we've done it
good morning from the east coast what
time is it mark
i will take the dub thank you
nice clean work and i will
invite another person about it
yeah it's very dark and drinking because
i know i tried to get you to join
but it didn't work let's try again
and then i will wait a bit see if it
works
beautiful let's roll
thomas is changing my life okay this is
tea
i've been drinking this i made this
before i started streaming it's not even
half empty
um and it's still hot who knew that the
thermos does exactly what it is uh
advertised as doing by function
huge fan i can't believe i still have
warm tea crazy
hello dark ninja welcome master bacon
emoji i believe that was you
hey man hey calm down out here
solid unit all right
i just need to put in some chills
that's why my cheeks are red no my
cheeks look especially red
um just because my uh i wasn't looking
for that at all oh my god
what just happened to us um my white
balance on my camera is really off
my cheeks actually probably are a little
bit red right now but um
it always makes me look pink or really
pale
um because i just don't care very much
about the way that i look but it is
definitely a thing stop telling me i
need to go faster i'm trying
[Music]
i'm pretty sure you don't have to hit it
exactly the boost button
uh a is boost if you're watching
i do not know
solid unit is on fire
um huh let's let the game
might be dc
they're leaving the game why is it is
are we getting dc's
is that what's happening here
i think it might be oh they're dropping
out because of explosions i don't know
that seems like there has to be some
other coincidence at play to have made
that
okay i think what happened scott
dc yeah so everyone just got dc'ed so i
guess i'm just gonna take this dub
which to be fair i deserve anyway
[Music]
okay because i've been in the lead for a
long while here okay we're not gonna
take the win away from me
also i just feel like if we can
acknowledge the improvement i've had
even
what since the beginning of the stream
um i've improved quite a bit get out of
the way keiko i didn't think that we had
any ai
and now i'm not going to get the dub so
what you're telling me oh that was so
close
all right i don't know what happened
uh i didn't deserve the win as it turns
out
you know what did occur is that i got
stupid because i thought nobody was left
um i still think i just have to win all
right i'm gonna clear the play i'll let
me entirely and then we'll invite new
people
i guess we could just go back to um
regular
uh arcade for a bit as well
don't play me please do that you're
still a cute little arcade
you're not upset beautiful
uh desert we're up to eight ball highway
yep cool invite only create
throw some invites
i will invite the people who deceived so
we can invite you again
because you got that dc for no reason
which is very unfortunate i'm unsure who
all of them were sadly um i know
scott we can reinvite you
wrong one got it invite and then i will
come back up here
a mortal junior you may join
sure i think you've got dc'd maybe two
record i don't like hearing my own voice
but hey happy to be here bye
cool i think you already played did you
not anything you have
no i just recognized my username from
youtube
and then go go back to the bottom i
think
sure i feel like i'm just screwing these
invites up now but
you know one person okay just one human
diego i'd be surprised if you're the
only one where uh
it's not morning um considering
you're still playing um it's night time
here in the us what time is it
10 13.
is it gonna do the thing where it blocks
out the last two and nobody can join in
them again
i do not know i do not know
it might
because it's strange that they haven't
been filled
i think you could tell you're uh not
only thank you for inviting me
welcome i don't know if yeet means you
want an invite either
nope okay that's gonna be it
i don't know why what i'm doing wrong
that causes this
no
we definitely have two players what is
it that i'm doing wrong
i'm unsure
you know ah i guess it just needs a bit
i do not know
[Music]
all right all right
[Music]
this is just a regular old arcade
it's okay diego you may you may message
me yeet
i just don't know if it means you want
an invite here's what i'm saying
the heat in itself is not an issue
no problems with the e
[Applause]
is this vegas again no i guess it is
desert
yeah if i didn't mention it though you
guys there is a link in the description
to where you can uh
check out more about this game if you
would like to get it yourselves for sure
i will probably continue to play um at
some other point
for achievement purposes because it's a
fun game
and in games like this that are pretty
simple that's generally how i play
get out of here keiko kaiko
do a great job on that corner
all right
got two possible on himself
oh geez
[Applause]
[Applause]
hey
out of the way
final lap paul this is gonna be a close
one
everyone's like right in the same spot
honestly ah
oh
that was dirty
oh my gosh
oh i'll take it but i wasn't positive it
would work and it did
try to invite someone again since we
still have the ai in here
there we go
the dark ninja is already in here
are you thank you to that player too
play yes okay green gulp
are you playing the game you do not
appear to be but i will send you an
invite
almighty dude i will also send you
another invite no worries let's do it
see if we can get another person in here
uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh i'll keep trying
cool cool cool now just kind of whoever
joins most
oh thank you center baby that's very
nice they're currently on youtube are
you watching this stream
on youtube on your xbox
hey ace mr funk is in here okay let's
roll
oh no hang on i didn't change the map
beautiful let's roll let's roll
that was a really good race that last
one was great it was really good
and i do really feel like um
you guys have watched me play in
relation to that comment
like i tested the game before streaming
but you very much watched me play from
beginning to end here
okay um i do not have hours of
experience but i feel like this is the
amount of time it took me to pick it up
like to actually oh this one
um to actually get it was probably about
45 minutes
which respect like i i prefer that it
takes a little bit of time
to be instantly doable so
[Applause]
also this car helps a lot
at least i feel that way
what is this tune all right
what a beat
[Applause]
hey
oh that one hurt me
um oh my god
i don't know what happened to your bud
but i'm sorry for your loss
uh what was i going to say oh yeah
i definitely mentioned all the other
things required but i did want to say
um this is a sponsored stream link is in
the description below if you'd like to
check the game out i'm having a great
time with it
um
we are playing on gas right now
[Applause]
don't play me like that
i just try to boost away from them so
they can't hit me because that's like
where i was really getting screwed in
some of those earlier races
it's like you just don't want people to
be able to oh
that wasn't good see i'll be able to hit
you
you know what i'm saying yeah it's not
the race that's hard it's all of the
the obstacles yeah
to be fair i don't feel like a lot of it
is intentional
but it does make things tough yeah oh no
[Applause]
no it's mostly an accident i didn't mean
to do that
whatever that was whoever that was i'm
sorry
oh the sun got faster on this one
absolute tune can i dj with this do you
think
no no no no no what have you done to me
that was unfair it was not fair
[Music]
oh just another
win in the worry about it
[Laughter]
after not doing well at the start i'm
just gonna revel in my wins
okay so oh wow
that's a cool achievement because they
pop up in both my pc and my xbox for
whatever reason
you're doing great thank you i
appreciate it i appreciate it i really
figured it out over the span of the
stream i feel good about it this game's
fun
this point i'm just going through all of
the maps which i feel pretty good about
we're up to jungle that was temple drive
dino dash
which we have already done so we'll do
it again
[Music]
um well i was playing in a stream for
like two and a half hours or so so we
probably got a couple more that we can
do
yeah i'll do like another 15 minutes
they only asked for two hours but this
is fun and now when there's people in
here
it's extra fun so i'll do a little bit
oh my screen that boost up
what okay never mind
i got very concerned look at you
oh oh oh i'm in t-rex hey bud
oh this is great you remember theme
parks remember we used to go outdoors
i'm paying too much attention to the
environment now though
[Applause]
not my finest not my finest racing
sorry about that hazel
it was not intentional i did not mean to
see you like that
[Music]
i don't know
all right i like this one it's a very
cute laugh
you go scotty hawkeye look at you go
[Applause]
dang we all boosted out of there
felt like i got wobbly there for a
second i did not
ah that wasn't good
there's a lot of mashing up against each
other on this one
oops sorry let me do there's an accident
[Music]
yeah i feel like we're all bunched up
here looks like we pretty much
are boosting out of the drifts is a good
time
hey hey
hey she jesus look at everyone
it's funny like because the fact that oh
no
ah um because we're all so close
together you can drop from like six to
first in like a second
what we were i don't know that that's
gonna happen for me now i might just
might have been screwed on that one a
bit
[Music]
let's break that up that was on me the
other one was not
okay it's not my fault i cannot be held
responsible
for the other one all right we caught up
we caught up
that's what we want caught up we made it
that was a good dress
oh mortal get out of the way
damn it wow hell of a finish
oh that was a good race it was a great
one
[Music]
oh thank you rachel i appreciate that
hey guys so i'm back here nathan hello
i did not quite hear what you said there
um all right we'll do like maybe like
two more that's what i'm gonna say
did i order from postmates today nothing
[Applause]
[Music]
you to get the boost you just have to
get it to be nice
no idea yellow on start you should be
sorry that was awful
um it has to be in the yellow on start
it's not uh it's not number based it's
not timing based rather oh my god i'm
just getting slapped about
i oh my god i was being hit myself
i don't know if i can recover from this
this is where i just got bullied
oh my gosh how far behind i am oh wow
that's okay hey can't win them all can't
win them
you can do it never give up i can try
that could be i wonder if there is a a
better way to recover
it's also a good question there are
recovery
strats people have
so when you get flipped it's a tough
time
[Applause]
i mean the more you boost or the more
you drift the more you get
boosts well that's what up to you guys
so let's take that
[Applause]
trying to avoid you there sorry mate
also there is drafting
hey
i sure did
oh this one's just we're just hitting
each other so much
including me i am also hitting people
it's happening to the best of us
difficult to avoid because it gets real
narrow
okay we recovered from the lost at the
beginning
[Applause]
so happy about that happy about that
look at that come back
i appreciate the support during that
difficult time hey
yeah it's okay when it happens when
you're
earlier in the game but when it happens
on the final lap it's uh it's like right
that's a tough sell i know and there's
always that other person that just
kills you that third party bummer
i'm happy with the recovery i'm happy
with the recovery
i have so much money oh my gosh
all right i'm gonna do one more and then
i'm gonna call it a night
i really need to clean my apartment
uh i think there's one more jungle
temple ruins we have already done let's
go talk to cargo chaos
let's roll last one baby
i don't use pillows that cover my chair
i use the back pillow i don't use the
top pillow because i find them annoying
they just put my neck forward
um i've never liked them very much
i don't think i've done this one
why did they suddenly introduce a pun in
the intro on that one where did that
come from
all right
didn't quite nail that that s drift
there that i was planning to
the song's back a bit tighter absolute
banger
this is a short one too it's pretty
chaotic
there's a neat dress in there though i'm
happy about it
ah those corners yikes fans
sorry the measurements information
oh okay doing all right do it all right
just the longest drift of all time
slowed me down a hell of a lot though
this is where it's gross
that that was some pro gamer [ __ ] until
it wasn't
i was doing great it's okay
this one's definitely definitely
requires some more thought more thought
i feel like it's a good
good last race for sure
[Applause]
i feel good about it though even if i'm
not winning that's like it feels good
it's so close
[Music]
i thought it was a great time i thought
it was super fun
and now i am rich loaded
um yeah it's
it's great i love it i'm uh i really
enjoy it
uh to everyone in this lobby i am gonna
have to leave you now but thank you for
joining me
not that you can hear me unless you're
watching the stream you've all been
great
thank you
alrighty everyone that is it for me
today this
stream was sponsored by hotshot racing
we played on multiple platforms
a couple of game modes um very fun
i really really enjoy it there is a link
in the description where you can check
it out yourself if you would like to
uh but otherwise i probably will
achievement hunt so feel free to if you
see me playing
um join in on me at some other point
but yeah thanks to everyone for joining
on my saturday night and all that good
stuff
and i will see you guys all next time